Let's summarize things and
wrap up this lecture.
I just want to repeat the points so
you so reinforcement learning is
something that we can use in trading.
The problem for reinforcement learning
algorithms is a Markov decision problem.
And reinforcement learning
algorithms solve them.
A Markov decision problem
is defined by S, A, T, and
R, where S is the potential states,
A are the potential actions,
T is a transition probability, which is
given I'm in state s, I take action a,
what's the probability I'll end up in
state S', and R is the reward function.
The goal for reinforcement learning
algorithm is to find a policy, pi,
that maps a state to an action that we
should take, and its goal is to find
this pi such that it maximizes
some future sum of the reward.
We talked about that being
either infinite horizon,
fixed horizon, or discounted sum.
We can map our task for
trading to reinforcement learning and
it works out like this.
S, our states,
are features about stocks and whether or
not we're holding a stock.
Actions are buy, sell, or do nothing.
The transition function here
is the market, and finally,
the reward function is how much
money we get at the end of a trade.
So, we can apply reinforcement learning
algorithms to find this policy.
We've mentioned a few of
those algorithms, for example
policy iteration, and value iteration,
and Q learning, but we haven't
talked in detail what they are, and
that's the subject of lessons coming up.
Okay, that's it for reinforcement
learning, I'll see you again soon.